When we first look at the composition of two function, we first evaluated a
function, add a number. And then we took that output and plugged it back into a
new function to get a new output. But we wouldn't want to do this every single
time for every single different number. Wouldn't it be nice if we just had one
function that could do the composition for us? This is what we're going to find
right now. F of g in terms of x. To find f of g of x, we're simply going to
take the entire function, g of x and plug it in for the variable x. We'll plug
this function into the other function as an input. So anywhere that we see x in
our function for f, we're going to replace it with x plus 5. So notice that I
have 3x here. So instead of 3x, I'll have 3 times, x plus 5, my new input.
Notice how I took the entire function of g of x. And I put it inside as the
input for f of x. Distributing this positive 3 will get the function 3x plus
15. This is the composite function f of g of x.